i think when i was 11 i had a seven and
a half hour surgery um around here on my
throat and neck
and that was like a long recovery that
was like five days in intensive care i
couldn't eat for a few of them so i had
to have
kind of iv ivory fluids
[Music]
when and how were you diagnosed so i was
dying i was in my condition uh type one
neurofibromatosis at the age of five
i was
messing around in my room one night
pretending to be whole cauldron
and kind of bounced my head off the uh
windowsill
and then the parents heard the the
screaming of their firstborn son ran
upstairs checked the furniture check the
child
and it came up in a bump
as you think it might do
and then we kind of iced it down left it
and then i did the exact same thing
again because
smart kid
and and this time it didn't go down and
so we started going into
talking to gps or what have you
and then you we got further and further
into the the system
and eventually got the the diagnosis
it's a genetic condition
that affects roughly one in every 2 300
births in the uk
and what it means is that um
your nerve tissues grow exponentially
well there's no one-size-fits-all to the
condition and i i've met hundreds of
people who who are affected by all of
whom present very differently
and so these these tumors can occur
anywhere on the human human body
it just happens that most of them are
like on my face and my upper torso
so it's just a really
random chance
thing it's the beauty and chaos of
genetics all at the same time
when you grow up with a
disability particularly a a rare
progressive one you spend a lot more
time in and out of hospitals and
you you mix in different worlds to your
to your counterparts and
i lost it it wasn't
unpleasant
it it
makes you grow up very quickly
what kind of surgeries did you have to
go through
absolutely so you have what they call
debunking surgeries where they
they go in and i try and remove as much
excess tissue as they can
without either being too heroic or
compromising
on things like healing and and muscle
movement
um that there are two kinds of
fibromyalgia if you've got the basic
ones that just sit on the nerves and you
can you can pluck those off quite easily
or you have plexiform ones that are also
wrapped around
muscle
bone and other
important tissue and i have a lot of
those
i think when i was 11 i had a seven and
a half hour surgery um around here on my
throat and neck
and that was like a long recovery that
was like five days in intensive care i
couldn't eat for a few of them so i had
to have
kind of iv iv fluids all in all i am now
up to 39
surgeries and number 40 is is in the
books
what were your teenage years like
oh well teenagers are awful anyway
aren't they you're just riddled with
angst you have this sort of like why me
why me my chemical romance emo
kind of mentality
i've always said that i'll allow myself
one good cry or one good moan over
anything
but then after that you've got to go out
and you've got to you've got to deal
with it and put it in its place
in in terms of the um playground economy
i was a really easy target for people to
kind of go after you you learn to cope
with it all by
getting on with it like you you walk
through it you take it in you process it
you allow yourself the space to
grease it
and then
you have to move on you can't carry all
this around with you
so forever let would be even more so
destroying
than the new bullying
building itself
how did you make a decision to have a tv
career
oh cranky i silence her into tv and the
bbc did a scheme called extend where
they recruit specifically for disabled
candidates i can say categorically that
the tv industry
has served the disabled community both
on screen and off screen completely
terribly and there is a real problem
with systemic systemic ableism in film
tv if you have a non-disabled person
presenting a disability documentary
that's just ridiculous and
and wishy-washy
and i think a lot of the time
when disabled people break into this
industry they're afraid to extend that
ground they don't want to be seen as
difficult or that guy
whereas i'll happily be that guy but
when you want to do something that
creates a positive change
someone has to be that guy there have
been
what
29 oscar nominations give or take based
on portfolio disability
and only two of those actors are
actually
disabled
and if you take if you were to take
those same kind of metrics and apply
them to racial gender
you'd be appalled and disgusted
and this idea that oh it's acting
um that argument falls down under the
weight of its own
own ignorance
completely normally when you see face of
this figure or visual different skin and
film it's used as like a shorthand
subjective heard organic
like if you look at the amount of um bad
guys who got scars or marks
and james bond is littered with them
no chance that i was the third one in a
row
which when you look at how much that
that young series has progressed in its
portrayal of women
i don't know why it continues to portray
this signal in in such a way
how did you get into acting from tv
i
applied for the rolling under the skin
as a joke
i was casting something for channel 4 at
the time
and i got a call from
changing faces who are the uk's largest
charity
that support people with um
disagreements and visual differences
saying hey if there's someone kind of
been in touch they want a guy with a
cigarette to maybe sort of kind of be in
a film
um here's another if you want to call
them
and so you know i gave a call i had a
chat
they asked me to send a paragraph like a
written paragraph about myself and i
didn't have time
so i sent my cv
and the opening gambit in my cv is my
name's adam pearson i'm the best in the
world at what i do
and no more no i don't even extrapolate
on it it's not like a really
media cv
and and they liked it and then they were
like can you put a clip of yourself on
youtube for the director so you can see
how you move and how you talk and and
what have you
and at this point i'm like sorry freaked
out and now i want all this to end so i
can get back to
normality quote unquote
so i upload this really sarcastic
youtube video where i make fun of both
my employers
star signs vegans
and then a dog appears in my arms out of
out of nowhere
and i had nothing for three weeks i'm
like yes got rid of them
i didn't get a call to go and meet the
director for one final meeting
um at the american church on technical
road
and on the way to that meeting i get hit
by a black town and break my leg
and at that point i'm like oh no and i
call the director i'm like hey funny
story just hit by a car my legs broken
i'm still really clean we're still
coming i'm just going to be about 10
minutes late
and then by this by this point i'm like
surrounded by like paramedics and
curious members of the public
and then he eventually turns up to the
scene as well by this point i'm just in
my pants
harness giraffe on walking
and he apparently the conversation went
lastly him oh glad you had him i didn't
realize he did your own stunt work
to which i apparently replied do i look
like i've got a stunt double
and then i go to ucl have to have leg
surgery
he comes in the next day um into the
trauma wing
and offers me the job and so then i got
a rehab and
fly to scotland to work with scarlett
johansson
i started enjoyed working on under the
skin i had a great crew
got to go hang out in scotland for a
couple of weeks
um both harry jonas and us are sorry
sorry lovely i couldn't have asked for a
safer set of hands to be in
in the world of social media there isn't
a lot of online trolls how do you
deal with them and
surely this may sound really weird to
say and it's not an invitation to do it
but there's a little part of me that
bloody loves it
because you can correct my grammar and
and move on
because a lot of trolling is is just
insecure individuals desperately wanting
attention
and so in a weird way i'm sort of
giving them what they want
almost
but there's also a level of illiteracy
that that comes with it where we social
media we write something we send it and
we forget it's there forever
like back in my day if you wanted to
read to someone you have to sign them
say it to their face and watch their
soul die right in front of you
and then you feel this good
old-fashioned emotion of rewards
whereas now you can type it send it and
feel all powerful
and it almost feels like there's no
consequences
to it whatever you send me i'll
screenshot it and i'll send it on
and in five years time it might come
back on
what's your health like now does your
condition keep on progressing okay the
condition will always keep on
progressing that's just the nature of it
and you you just you
you schedule your appointments you talk
to your experts and you you go in when
you have to
and you you've always got to keep having
it done
like hospitals and surgery and medicine
will always be a part of my life
part of managing one's disability or all
one circumstances is knowing when things
are too much and knowing when to ask for
help
and there's there's no shame in that and
i think particularly
for young men they just feel kind of
like alpha mentality as
kind of no i got this i got this it's
all going to be good it's all going to
be good
and until you reach a true breaking
point where you realize things aren't
good
and so i think there's there's a great
deal of strength in kind of reaching out
to help realizing
when things are too much at any given
moment
and
and working through it i think it's okay
not to be okay i think sometimes the
world does get on top of you
and i don't think it's all necessarily
down to my disability and and i can't
change my circumstances what i can
change how i feel about them
and invariably how you feel about them
does change
over time and you you acknowledge it you
adapt and you you adjust as long as you
can be unashamedly yourself because
everyone else frankly is is taken
you'll
you'll forget
[Music]
that snowballed into thoughts of i'm
never
going to be intimate with anybody i'm
never
going to have a family i'm never going
to experience love because i look like
this
if i had a face like yours if i had eyes
like yours i'd be happy